foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back how the hell are you see you
man good to see you it's good to be back
in the city Lisa the guest bartender is
here hello everyone looking good great
eyebrows Sally you're welcome I didn't
see you at the cellar party I saw you
across the room I couldn't make it to
you there was too many obstacles but you
walked in in the Hawaiian shirt looking
like a Hitman yeah
oh it was great I saw you across the
room too and you another guy couldn't
get to it's so frustrating like the
people you want to talk to you never get
to yeah I mean obviously I talk to a lot
of people I love but but there were
definitely some obstacles in there
there's definitely a couple of parasites
who are like hey and you're like damn it
I gotta be stuck with this cleave for
six minutes Christmas party in April
what the Passover
no they just always do the holiday party
late because I think their logic is
everyone to the holiday party in
December we'll do a holiday party in
April because good point we're not
competing with any parties yeah and it's
a crazy spread it's open bar it's every
comic and you're like well you're still
doing it
I forgot about you and uh yeah it was
fun Liz was doing a lot of those you're
still doing it oh yeah there's a lot of
those how do you pay the rent I have a
few Comics I have a list of eight Comics
I'm like how do you pay a New York rent
you never do the road you never do Clips
or TV or anything but it'd be great if
the party was just one giant
intervention for a comic like how do you
do it yeah please quit they literally
came there for the food yeah yeah right
right the food was I mean we've got that
Kennedy Fried Chicken which was a little
hey a little lukewarm and the
temperature I want a hot piece of
chicken I was a little upset I still ate
it I know I get stereotypical guys mad
about the food temp but
it was a little drafty in there
um this may be a little inside baseball
but the comedy seller bought the
McDonald's
on West 3rd Street that's right right
next to the fat black that was like the
world star yes McDonald's yes totally
that was like where every Sucker Punch
was thrown late at night yeah that's
right it was a big like drag queen
McDonald's one comic got beat up by a
couple drag queens a few years ago I
remember
which uh who got beat up by a drag queen
Artie Fuqua really yeah he got a new
with a couple drags he's quick too you
think he'd be able to hold his own well
that was like six of them yeah and it is
dudes after all so that's that's how
Progressive New York City is the drag
queens are beating up non-drag queens
yeah that's right and they just here we
go hey
what's shaking fatty get over here
oh yeah hey hey
welcome
to meet you salacus
what do you got a hog out there
oh I ride them every drag queen had the
hug
Let's uh good to see you man we just
started
you didn't miss anything well we got you
your drink of choice was I believe a
cucumber gin yes sir very a very summery
uh request which I appreciate I love a
good summer cocktail if we're day
drinking I want it to be summer you
don't want like I love whiskey I don't
want it 2 p.m yeah I want it at night
yeah the brown Liquors no offense but
the brown Liquors I feel like are better
at night we drink a lot of brown Liquors
that's brown people oh yeah I don't know
why we haven't been in a whiskey
commercial just yet yeah you guys don't
get in that when are you getting those
I think Indian people are ashamed of how
much we drink alcohol really I think so
I didn't know you guys were known to be
booze bags that's why you own all the
liquor stores ah good point vertical
integration no need for a middleman
you're getting high in your own Supply
don't hell yeah there you go oh that's
my first alcoholic beverage was
at my I stole some of my dad's whiskey
from his store and I kept it in the
garage
and I was like 8th grade ninth grade I
would take a little nip oh yeah I mix it
with orange juice and brought it to
school to share with my friends and I
chickened out I couldn't drink it at
school I felt that whiskey OJ yeah oh
that's like my first drink not the right
time I don't know what I was doing dude
I just saw my dad drinking it must be
cool damn Dear Dad owned a liquor store
yes sir look at that let's all locking
in there it is do you remember what kind
of whiskey it was Johnny Walker black
that's a that's a solid whiskey yes but
as a kid you're not no kid appreciates
no no the Nuance no kid is like that's
that's a good stuff put it with
Tropicana dude
when you're young and you the first time
you get like a good bottle and you and
you're too dumbed you don't know you're
supposed to have it straight and you get
that liquor snob he was like what are
you doing I know yeah we did a lot of uh
Country Time lemonade and vodka oh
that's that's pretty good it wasn't bad
but it's all sugar that's a hangover and
a half yeah screwdrivers are good OJ and
vogs sure and your kid a cranberry vodka
yeah it's a breakfast drink of alcohol I
like it we're just telling kids what to
drink if you were if you're 13 years old
don't waste a good scotch yes mix it
with soda kids a lot of pop off when
you're a kid without the Vodka it's like
shitty vodka oh the plastic bottle no we
we did uh all the banana flavored one
Smirnoff banana all the [__] green
apple all that [__] yeah that's what you
thought was cool I know when you're a
kid yeah I mean I feel like that's who's
drinking uh what's what's the cinnamon
whiskey Fireball oh Fireball if you're
an adult when you drink that you are
just classless yeah you're on you're
outside of Port Authority
in which case you're pretty high class
right true I don't like any of those I
got peanut butter whiskey now I'm like
come on I tried that on Santino's
podcast
you guys have your own whiskey right we
do oh yeah we have to have it yeah
it's Nutella flavored so dude I just
thought Norman loves Nutella and I just
saw it again pull up the Nutella
nutritional this is gonna break your
heart what's in it it's like the least
healthy what no way the last ingredient
is a hazelnut right
oh no no but there's like a breakdown of
what it's like really it's like all
sugar and then like a dash of hazelnut
can you read that clearly because I
cannot and I'm wondering if I should get
LASIK
oh no I can't either I can't see this
[__] at all two tablespoons two spoons I
don't know it was on Twitter so I don't
know wow 12 grams of fat 21 grams of
sugar
but it was like grosser when they showed
the actual breakdown I believe it ah
they're tall that's my n-word
well you always think it looks it's like
expensive and it's foreign so I always
assumed it was healthy is it foreign I
believe it's from like you feel like
you've been here with you when you eat
like a ferio Rocher Nestle Crunch but
it's all gone I think very Rocher is
Nutella yes hazelnut cream in the middle
yeah yeah my buddy used to wear this
shitty cologne and he was like it's
Italian but he still smelled like an
[__]
but it was Italian it was important
man him bad things those bad stuff
overseas why is imported just sound
better it just sounds because it's not
here it's like a Cuban cigar yeah
because the good stuff is imported and
you assume if it's important it's good
but bad stuff is awesome yeah the
Chinese all the Chinese [__] is
important
good point I had a friend come over from
France and he only wanted to drink
Budweiser while he was here he's like
this is a good stuff I was like it's not
the good stuff is he trans all right
what's with the Pepto
she's a drinking pot and we have weak
stomachs oh really yeah oh dude I was
he's got an ulcer oh my God I have
stomach pain I was not made to be a
drinker you got coffee going right now I
know I take horrible care of myself
a lot of coffee alcohol and then yeah I
gotta slip Pepto I do a little I do
peppermint pills occasionally yeah so
see us on the road now because we'll be
dead in six years
slippery [__] slope here you guys
have set up this is an afternoon
drinking podcast you think we're doing
well that's why I brought my helmet
should I be wearing a helmet because I
City bike every day
yeah that's like the you're supposed to
wear a helmet at all times dude do you
see how people drive in this city you
don't wear a helmet I've had some close
calls you'll be wearing a helmet in no
time if you're not wearing a helmet
right now
man damn he was riding a scooter without
a helmet you don't wear one either yeah
but you're on a motor motorbike doing it
that's true all over the city 45 no
helmet usually you bike around town you
should be wearing a helmet just not very
dorky but you know I mean the Stephen
dorky would be dead good points why is
safety dorky it is I guess it just looks
dumb there's condoms nerd there's no
cool looking helmets that's true you
know there's no you should get one that
says like [__] the police on it you're
like that guy's cool that guy's a man
maybe I'll just get one that says I'm
special needs because no one will [__]
with me then they'll then they'll make
fun of me let me be like that guy's
pretty cool yeah he's high functioning
you waved him it's like yeah
[Laughter]
he's got his helmet says why he's doing
that I'm Downs with the cars all right
well you know in Connecticut they do all
these like people are always fighting so
they don't have to wear helmets the
bikers yeah but it's like you riding a
motorcycle without a helmet you're just
asking a [__] die everyone crashes on
a bike so I fell off my scooter I got
knocked out no helmet construction
workers had to bring me to the sidewalk
really it was wild yeah and yet you're
still not wearing a helmet whoa I didn't
die
how bad was the injury it was pretty bad
I I've hit a bump and I flew off the
front of the handlebars and I had gloves
on it was Winter and I scraped them and
they were they were it was just all skin
because I scraped the glove off and you
got knocked out got knocked out you have
CTE for the future now yeah yeah no
helmet he'll be shooting up a bank in no
time
I wore the reason I started wearing
helmet is because I got blackout drunk
like during summer pandemic and I was on
a city bike and I like rode home with no
I had my helmet but I didn't have it on
oh boy and like I don't know how the
[__] I got home and that's like the
scariest thing come home and have your
wife yell at you like you could have
[__] died
that's the scary part yeah your wife's
just yeah yeah you wish I died sleeping
on the sofa but you didn't fall no I did
not I've had I've had two close calls
one where like the City by gear didn't
shift correctly yeah and my shin hit the
the pedals and I like flew into a car oh
and and then the second time where I had
seen the I was like riding up to where
the stop is where you Docker [__] yeah
and there was a dip in the sidewalk and
I didn't see it because I was just
flying at [__] boom right into my
nuts
brutal luckily luckily I didn't fly over
the handlebars that time because that
would have been bad right damn there's
no helmet for the nuts like this is a
cup there's a Cup's so dorky too if
you're doing that then then you were a
door yeah like unless you're like
playing I guess if you like play
baseball or something that you would but
remember you played baseball you put the
cup on you like how do people move when
this yeah only did it when I was
catching every other position it doesn't
make it since you never really get hit
in the nuts yeah yeah you have to be
asking for it to get in the nuts
out yeah good point yeah it goes in the
yeah in the dirt yeah UFC guys wear cups
yeah they have weird colors they're kind
of like cylindrical kicked in the balls
constantly not on purpose but it's just
Flying Kicks definitely on purpose it's
probably yeah some people fake a nut hit
because it gives them five you get five
minutes so if you're getting your ass
kicked and you fake a nut hit you're
like oh I'll go over here and regroup
for five and it kind of helps you with
the fight huh you've been learning these
strategies from Rogan I see hanging out
with Joe a little too long I'm a UFC
dude now I let him kick me once and it
was not broken
yeah why would you do that I just said
give me like a softie on the ass and I
flew across the room wow yeah
it doesn't help that he's four foot two
all that leverage yes he's like a little
tank yeah it's a brick of a man kicking
you in the lake oh yeah he is like a
hard he's like he's just hard he's solid
yeah he's got a huge hog by the way does
he you've seen it sought at the urinal
it was after you got kicked in the ass
all right Mark it's like this will make
you feel better huge I don't know what's
thicker his dick or his neck but uh
large a large piece on the guy both are
holding up a big head
it says on it on the side what's that
hey cocktail yeah
oh you drink with the guest drinks of
course oh that's amazing not always I
think recently that every once in a
while we surround it's good to drink the
same yeah yeah camaraderie gracias thank
you very much thank you so much so this
is uh so it's just gin and soda with the
Cucumber garnish there's a cucumber
flavored love a model oh this is my
drink of choice of lime
and gin thank you very much his mother
was a mother yeah
hey cheers hey thanks for coming cheers
oh hey cheers all good damn that smells
nice
[Music]
um
um that's a good summer drink it goes
down easy oh yeah too easy I'm gonna be
cursing at immigrants pretty soon this
is a drink we're going to the party
I remember when nemesh used to run that
hot show bar match those with Michael
Che and Mike Denny and Mike Denny don't
forget dinner as well I'm sorry Mike
Denny hope you're doing well Denny and
we and we would do that show remember we
would get wasted at yourself that was
like the show I remember one time I got
taken out I was so drunk the bartender
removed me in a headlock oh really yeah
I only remember this because you text me
you go man you looked rough last night
like the one person who checked in on me
oh I'm sorry man I don't know what I did
to get taken out but it was probably bad
they had a they had a pretty high bar to
get removed so yeah he must have been
done some wild [__] especially with Che
was fall down drunk every week yeah we
were we were drunk pretty often and uh I
was one of you were just I was just
thinking about matches the other day
because I was in Green Point and walked
past it yeah I was like it's gone is it
it's like uh been demolished now they're
putting up damn it's they're putting up
high rises or that was a great condos
yeah
yeah I mean that area was like when
Williamsburg kind of becomes Green Point
yeah and it was a cool it was a green
point is still kind of cool yeah yeah
yeah the Polish have held on yes because
they're still there holy [__] they're so
good wow that's gone we used to watch
Lost there remember when lost was a
thing we'd all go and watch Lost on the
big screen and get drunk yeah that's an
underrated thing it's like I love my
favorite thing is in the playoffs when
they you go to a bar and the sound is on
oh the best that is the greatest thing
that's a big New Orleans thing where are
you watching tomorrow
I'm going to be in La so I'll be
watching in L.A I actually just had to
move a podcast because with the time
change I didn't realize that it was a
Knicks game like scheduled like weeks
out and I was like [__] the Knicks play
game too yeah I completely understood
yeah I could have made up a different
excuse and I was like it's game two and
they're like we totally get it yeah I'm
surprised not going to Cleveland
it'd be fun to go I did someone's radio
show and he was like I thought you'd be
at the game and you're just at home with
Stavros just screaming at a TV and I was
like it's in Cleveland yeah just travel
with the team tickets are probably
cheaper they are definitely cheap you
know are you gonna go on Thursday is it
I'm gonna be on the west you're still in
there like God damn sorry how much is
the average playoff tickets for the
Knicks I think it well it depends Sam's
got it
both of y'all but wait a minute back to
matchless yes it's sad it's gone so many
good times you were giving out those
drink tickets like that's what it was
yeah I mean we you're the reason it
closed every Monday night we we dropped
like a 20 tip at the bar and like that
should cover everybody for the inside
tonight right well that was the only bar
where you'd use a drink ticket and
they'd give you top shelf yeah yeah
every other Bond they're like this is
for well imagine you're drinking I'd get
a Johnny Walker black and orange juice
[__] dude it was the best because like
those bartenders were there like when it
was like three people in the room
so when we got to you know what it
became when you guys were doing it
regularly it was like
they saw us grow from they became
friends with all those people Sarah and
RM and all them like in the so they were
just like yeah just get [__] up we
don't give a [__] cause
before Monday nights when we were doing
it they had nothing going on nothing
that part would have closed a lot sooner
I think a lot of people for sure and
neighborhood people which is good yeah
it's good when it becomes like a
neighborhood thing started with Hannibal
right Hannibal at it first then gave it
to you no he had Knitting Factory no
Hannibal had done a show there that's
what it was done had done a show there
uh and I think he did one or two there
and then I think he moved to knit after
that or something and then uh Denny had
a show in the basement of a bar in the
basement of a FedEx called illegal FedEx
and we were in there for like three or
four episodes of broken and then somehow
he found that bar and we're like all
right let's do it there and it became
just like
more like we will build this as opposed
to okay this is going to be like uh um
like a chore or anything be like we're
super excited to make it something out
of nothing and yeah we're two years in
at that point right how else do you find
stage time you guys had a hot show what
was it I had a couple different
locations we had I when I first was
starting I had to show in Times Square
called sage stand up and it was killer
that was a good show that was like a
better show than we were yes yeah you
know what I mean when did you start what
yeah yeah a long time ago
um I was 0-9
yeah that was before that it was like it
was uh that was like a Times Square hot
show and then there was uh we moved it
to a venue called Hurley's which is like
where Johnny Carson used to get [__]
up yeah it was like a classic old school
bar but uh they they were such [__]
to us at Hurley's it was a bummer
because it was but then that was back
when like Times Square was still good
for comedy in a weird way because we
would hand out flyers and create word
and it was like people would walk in
they would just walk in yeah so you'd
get a lot of randos right now I feel
like Times Square is terrible terrible
you know but uh and then after that the
last one was bar 82. oh that was a hobby
that was it was another cool bar that
closed down it was Village yeah it was
like a grimy cool old school I don't
look like where they would like shoot a
casavetti's film or something like yeah
I feel like I've done a show at Hurley's
I don't know if it was your show it
definitely wasn't your show it might
have been my show
that's why I became friends with a lot
of people I mean that's where I became
like closer friends with like Joe list
and Dan sodas like they do your show and
you start having a drink and hanging out
they were still drinking yeah oh yeah
that was a long time I just realized
both of them quit wow our Godsey bargazi
was legless every night
good time and you did hot soup was that
uh what was the one on 14th Street with
Andy Haynes Matt Ruby Gary veter was on
o'hanlon's on 14th Street that was a fun
one big booze booze that was every
Friday night and then we got kicked out
of there because we they caught a
sneaking in booze then we went to I
remember sneaking in booze at that place
why did you sneak boozing I don't know I
couldn't afford it yeah we don't want to
pay for Booze got it yeah we I remember
bringing in like a Dasani bottle Full of
Bourbon yes and just everyone taking a
swig of it being like wow we're [__]
trash
well they probably wouldn't have charged
us either but maybe I think they maybe
probably before they probably did I
think that's why you sneak it in they
were probably charging yeah then we
moved Irish exit that that was the show
yeah that was the show I think uh for me
like oh I got I respected you and Gary a
lot and Ruby and I was like I gotta go
do this show everyone's [__] doing it
and I just popped in and I was like God
didn't like this is how fun a bar show
could be and we would just a tiny little
stage yep in that back room it was kind
of a perfect setup for comedy but
terrible location for comedy but it
works there's an East Side Midtown yeah
and you've got a lot of east east side
Midtown people it would be like Finance
Bros with their like dates and you just
talked they were good yeah they were fun
they had a lot of fun remember Phoebe
Robinson had that showcase in the
Mondays oh yeah and it was literally a
it was a hostage situation
it was in Midtown that's why I thought
of it but it was like in the first side
and remember you'd go on stage and every
night it was a it was a hostage
situation but yeah she'd get on stage
and be like all right you guys ready for
comedy people would like turn around
they just got off work and they're like
no
and that would be the show I remember
bombing for like it was like four people
in the crowd and they were all kids that
went to Tulane I wish I went to team and
they all like I all told them I'm
leaving school to pursue stand up this
is where they see me a four-person crowd
of only them and I just bombed from a
few people oh what are the others who I
just told I was pursuing my dream to and
they're like well clearly this isn't
working this isn't going to work out for
you but that that show was rough raw
that would be like okay can you turn off
the hockey game and they'd go no
get funnier yeah brutal the best show I
mean the best show that I bombed at when
Jared had you were there it was senior
bomb quite a bit Yeah there's been a lot
of bad shows I bombed that but the best
show I bombed at was Jared has a show in
the Upper East Side remember stumble in
yeah
the J train shows oh yeah like those
were like when we start when because he
was uh we started almost at the same
time maybe a year later he started maybe
a year later and he was like I know how
to make a lot of friends he was working
at a as a at a financial advisory shop
or whatever and so he had this huge like
roll call of people and we'd go Upper
East Side so funny that he used it for
stand-up I mean oh yeah yeah a huge
Network and it was like all people his
age our age smart popping fun first show
I did I crushed I was like oh this is
awesome second he did a week later it
was me you Che yep and a few other
people and I went up and I did basically
the same set I had done the week prior
ate a [__] monster dick was it the
same crowd I guess I'm not sure it was
the same type of people I don't remember
seeing the same uh interesting I ate
such a [__] dick and then I think Che
went up after me you had went up you
went up before me and you destroyed I
went up a to dig Chay went up afterwards
he struggled a little I think too no he
he struggled right after a little bit
right after he opened but he opened with
like he was trying to defend me said uh
if you wanna if you want to try stand up
go on stage and pull your dick out and
for whatever reason that like ripped
wow then he went up and did his thing
but I remember isn't it funny how you
remember every detail of these bombs oh
my God like I was that it was at that
show I decided I would never do that
material ever again wow because I
realized you we and I talked about it
it's like that the bit I was doing is
about like carrots and celery and [__]
and it's a really stupid silly bit that
required a lot of momentum and if I
didn't have at the beginning it was just
gonna be me bombing for three minutes
because you couldn't get out of the bit
yeah and I didn't have the chops to be
like oh I should abandon this
[__] at this point there's no
worse feeling than when you're in the
middle of a bit that you know is long
yeah
[Music]
I just want to start sweating like oh
man trapped it's worse it happened to me
I did a private event uh last week and
it was it was a pretty damn rough set
it's one of those sets where you're like
I'm thinking about [__] I'm gonna buy
with this money that you're making me
[__] suffer yes what type of crowd
it was some guy's birthday oh [__] but
yeah and I remember leaving uh I was in
the middle of a bit that I knew I
probably shouldn't have done it but you
just want to do your newer stuff of
course so I did I opened I go into it
and I'm like
it was I had the trap door out of the
bed because I was like this isn't this
is like a five minute bit and it's going
to [__] bomb yeah I was like a minute
in I was like [__] this you can feel it
I bailed on it and then just yeah he had
to I mean he's like it's I'm cool I'm
gonna eat it yeah you had the
professional awareness like oh this is
going to be poor you know two years in
you're just like oh this is I'll find a
way out of this did not there's no worse
feeling than when you go I mean there's
worse feelings but like as a perform
when you go on and they're just talking
oh yeah and you're like what do you what
am I a [__] magician I need your uh
yes I need something and then they go uh
you're not funny I'm like well you have
to listen to the setup right yeah how
would I be how am I gonna laugh you
don't hear the setup and the punch I
hate that no bomb you can't even I've
been in a situations where you can't be
like will y'all shut the [__] up I know
because they're there for them exactly I
know I did a charity like last year a
year and a half ago and I was supposed
to head I was headlining it and
like two other people went up and no one
was paying attention and the people that
invited me were like the heads of the
organization sitting right next to me
they're talking yeah the whole group is
talking I'm just trying to be like at
like I'm supposed to do 30. I did like
18 and at one point I just told like the
biggest sponsors of the event to shut
the [__] up I was like yo listen y'all
need to shut the [__] up I'm not gonna
lose confidence in any of this material
yeah I'm not the one doing poorly here
you're supposed to be paying attention
and I just sweat through the whole
[__] thing and then afterwards the
organizers like hey that was really good
guys I was sorry that everyone was tough
I feel like that carrot shadowy material
should have worked exactly not
so many bombs it's so demoralizing those
corporates when they're talking they
don't pay attention you're like I'm
getting a lot of money but why'd you
book me I know that's really what it is
you're like you just have to accept that
you're like this isn't yes this isn't me
being an artist yes this isn't I'm not
even an Entertainer here I'm a monkey
it doesn't matter if you do well there
don't do well there it's literally just
a picture you just yeah you just you
just are like oh man I love this and I
feel yeah this is look world's smallest
violin here that come on it's not that
big a deal but you feeling like [__] I'm
always thinking about what's the
opportunity I'm gonna get out from this
that's that's always in the back of my
head I'm like there's always other
people at charity events that are like
oh he did great or Mike but maybe we'll
book them for that and then you just eat
a dick it's like whoa that guy [__]
sucked yeah you know Jonathan Katz used
to have a great joke where you'd say I'm
doing a benefit next week for the
survivors of the week I did the for the
benefits
it's a great joke but uh he's a funny
guy he's a funny guy dry very dry so I
got I got shouted out by Seinfeld and
that year I got like a million corporate
gigs because they're like oh Seinfeld
likes this guy and I bombed at every one
of them they hate it because you know my
ACT is like so what's up with uh Puerto
Ricans or whatever and people are like
Whoa We got HR here what are you doing
you're the Seinfeld guy I got 12 minutes
on squirting they weren't having it
I've only I've done like five corporates
and they've all been like
four of them were great because they
were booked through like the I used to
work for these people oh come to our
event like we love you and then like I
would like research them and all that
like you know build the community or
build the set after talking to the
community people but one of them I did a
doctor's conference in San Antonio
after after crushing the year before I'd
done a doctor's conference some doctor
there was like come do this like small
or private event for like just this
Hospital group and I was working on this
Healthcare stuff like oh this is gonna
go great yeah and I went up and I called
I basically called them prostitutes and
like it was like it was like
yeah family event
[Music]
luckily you got booked to the sex
workers conference
yeah no that happened to me once I got I
killed a corporate and they were like
you're you're our guy now we'll bring
you back the next year and I was like
great and I remember doing it again the
next year and this year I'm coming in
cocking like these people are cool they
know that's always when you know you're
gonna eat [__] when you come in like oh
you're not gonna eat [__] and I go up
and uh the mic goes out and they're like
just keep just keep going I'm like no
you don't understand this is the only
thing I need yes exactly the only thing
I need is a mic and I just I'm talking
they're just like we don't
so it's one of those bombs where like it
happened slowly like I first couple
jokes kind of Hit the mic and then the
mic goes out and then I'm just still
talking they're like aha because like
two minutes later they're all just
talking the table and I'm like of course
all right
just count the minutes will you shut the
[__] up yeah I've uh definitely [__] a
couple of gals at these corporations
yeah that's the nice thing because you
know they've all [__] each other so
you're the guy coming in with the
microphone and you're the new guy
pretty easy to get laid at these these
Christmas party because then everybody
gets hammered too
yeah and also if you do well you're
you're like a superhero who's this guy
who just showed up in his funny so
what's it like what made you want to do
comedy yeah I thought I want to do I'm
pretty fun you think I could do it no
there's a lot of that no Brit a lot of
these yeah a lot of the broey guy like
hey man that was pretty good he gets you
in a headlock
I did wanna for a pharmacy
pharmaceutical uh conference bombing
bombing and I snapped you know what
you're like [__] you guys you're all
drug dealers you think you're killing
people opioid addiction and then they
they kicked me off and I gave me some
Xanax yeah
um yeah those are
those are tough because you're like it
just sucks when you know people when you
leave and they're like that guy's bad I
think that's the feeling exactly because
you're like because those gigs you are
usually playing the hits I think that's
of course in your mind you're like these
are bull I think that's what hurts yes
you know this is your throw in 95 you're
throwing heat and well you're shooting
baskets but they're not counting them
like that went in they're like nah that
sucked like it went in yeah it feels
rigged and I did the one where I went
that worked on The Tonight Show which is
the most [__] sassy uh condescending by
the way it's like that worked on a a
really hot crowd why is
pharmaceutical benefit it worked on a
comedy show you know it's it's insane
but it's like that ego thing we were
like I'm not I don't want you to leave
thinking I'm bad yeah that's really what
it is but they will they will the worst
is you still gotta eat
like dinner that they haven't served
yeah oh I always stick around sit at
your table yeah you know one of the best
ones I ever did was was I don't know if
I've told this on the podcast before but
I did a gig years ago for the New York
Rangers oh the Legends and it was hosted
by Kenny Albert have I told this story
Kenny Albert you know Marv Albert's son
he's a great guy Kenny he's a great
broadcaster but he's hosting the show it
was like the weirdest gig it was uh like
Trump Golf Course in Connecticut or
something I just got in a car I know I
was going and
Coca-Cola it's like a corporate thing
but it's also the Rangers so I remember
I uh I'm talking to Al Troutwood
remember Al trautwig he's dude he's like
an Anchorman character he reeks of
scotch I was like oh man out trautwick I
loved you growing up he goes well I
haven't seen your work so my opinion
remains to be seen I was like Jesus this
guy's got an attitude yeah by the way he
did not become a fan that night so I
remember uh Kenny is you know the MC
he's kind of just he's not a comic he's
just kind of leading the thing and all
these Rangers Legends of the rod Gilbert
I'm talking to who passed away a couple
years ago who's like the nicest guy ever
like could not have been a cooler guy
and then I bomb so hard that I remember
I get off stage in Adam grave so you
guys know Adam Graves yeah Ranger is
great yeah start comes over to me and
you can just see him searching his brain
to find anything nice to say to me yeah
this is what he comes up with
I love humor
[Laughter]
and Kenny Albert sitting there with me
goes I can't believe you just did that
like he's like I can't believe you
bombed that hard
I was like it's free food yeah yeah
that's a lot of balls oh yeah but you
got it but he was he was not he was like
he was like the one dude laughing in the
corner so I was like you like feel as
long as like one person is enjoying it
yeah I feel like a psycho oh yeah or
someone comes up I was like man I've
seen you before you yes you're good you
deserve better yeah that's the best they
were they were shitty yeah that goes a
long way you ever have that like a
weekend when you're a young comic and
someone from the staff comes up like you
deserve better yeah sorry just bombed
all weekend you deserve better than this
weekend it's bittersweet because they're
like being nice but they're also like
you're really tanked out they're bad we
got less tips because of you right
[__] I think worst gig I've ever done
was Radio City warming up for the VMAs
this is a classic I won't tell the whole
story but they put me on before the show
so you gotta like warm up but nobody
cares no so you go out there and I'm
like hello hello and they're all just
like tweeting and look at each other and
like JLo walked by it was I was supposed
to do 50 minutes I think I did eight and
the guy was doing this with the headset
he's like off get off oh it was so bad
Adam no Scott Rogowski was there he
texts me when he took a photo with me
bombing that he could take a picture
like a selfie oh it's brutal Scott's a
mutual friend and Scott texted me he
goes why are they doing this to normal I
was like doing what he goes he's bombing
at the VMAs I was like what yeah I
didn't know he was doing were you
bombing because they were paying
attention and uh uh the jokes were just
not hitting or you were bombing because
everyone's just talking to each other
and you couldn't get over them they'd
even I might as well not have been there
they thought I was like a like a grip no
that's not a that's not a comedy crowd
to begin with no it's doing the I
remember Dane Cook did a set like at the
peak of Dane Cook's Fame on TV and he
bombed oh yeah you're not good yeah
you're not doing well no Ariana Grande
walked in the whole [__] place turned
to look at her and I was like hey how
about her I [__] her
say anything
yeah and they didn't like that I want to
hear it didn't even register boots was
there OOTS was in the crowd for some
reason he was filming me and laughing
like look at this piece of [__] Comics
it's hilarious yeah because you know
that that's the thing is like Leonard
knows Mark's hilarious so it's like one
of the things where you're just like
this is awful is just laughing at the
decision sometimes you can say no marker
yeah you don't have to do the VMA but
you know what you got a story yeah I got
a story then they pick you up on a limo
I brought the lady you gotta do it of
course it's a VMAs you gotta do it I got
personally thrown out of a venue by
Chuck Berry whoa whoa did he pee on you
so I was supposed to photograph him and
I was talking backstage and he's like
Barry he's like you can't photograph me
on stage uh backstage but you I'll
invite you on stage you can take your
picture
okay so I'm like it's been 90. no it was
like 2008.
he's still performing like Chuck Berry
very good yes what 2007. 008 is he still
alive no he's dead now yeah uh so he's
like I'm gonna invite you on stage you
can take your picture then in the middle
of the show so like before that happens
I'm just like taking some pictures from
you know off stage and he points at me
and I was like oh this is my moment so I
start walking up and he was like get
that guy out of here
and like the crap it was like a WWE work
the crowd was like yeah
they throw you out they did
my pasta primavera and I left wow wow I
don't follow what you did were you hired
uh I was shooting for a magazine I think
the whole thing was a work just to get
like the crap oh
yeah and I don't think he wanted me to
shoot before he asked me to shoot got it
and I think that's what I really did can
you pull this up can you pull up Richard
Pryor live in concert because there's a
guy in the beginning who keeps taking
photos of him and Richard pry's like get
the [__] out of here it's gold I love
that they left that in ain't no film in
the camera yeah yeah exactly
that opening is so weird because it's
just people are just like seated I know
but it kind of works no it's amazing I
mean that's probably his best special
easily easily but the end of sunset
strips is Best Bet what's that one again
the uh Jim Brown oh yeah so funny that's
a great one
no this is Sunset Strip you got to go to
live in concert
I'm in concert
it's crazy he he's like known as the
best comic of all time and he has what
three hours
but you got his albums on Spotify are
like there's a billion of them oh okay
my favorite
probably the Africa bit
oh yeah
uh you gotta go to two minutes right I
don't think this is the right one no
yeah that's not it he's wearing the red
shirt yeah that's it
I think it's the one at the top there
live in concert
Oh weird
all right well so funny that Netflix has
it I know Netflix says Eddie Murphy too
he's he drops the F-bomb like I don't
know 38 times in the first six not all
comedy age is great no
although those jokes are aged well yeah
we watched it like a week ago it's still
fun no no this special is amazing Yeah
Yeah Eddie Murphy's insanely fun he's
got it yeah he's like a Phenom 22 in
those years
like how I don't think you should do
stand up again what do you guys think
what is he there was that whole rumor
that he was gonna do it and it was 80
million dollars right and then he just
did he not accept it I mean what
happened he was going to do stand-up
yeah Netflix was gonna pay him 80
million right yeah the problem is it
would require him going out and working
it out and bombing and and failing and
he's so famous that him showing up at
like The Comedy Store would be a
Paparazzi thing like oh yeah it's can a
guy like that actually work out material
in private is the question yeah I mean
you just Yonder everything oh that's a
good call
you I haven't seen you didn't see Louie
working his stuff out
publicly nothing leaked but Eddie Murphy
this is like over 30 years in the making
it's different than Louis I think it's a
bigger thing but you'd still be dropping
into the clubs that we're doing and just
be like I'm gonna do a weekend here like
Monday Tuesday Wednesday true right I
wonder if he's worried I mean
I'm I'm just playing devil's advocate
here I wonder if he's worried talking to
Eddie Murphy yeah about people just
seeing him weak that's what I'm saying
yeah because you have to be because
maybe people audience see this Comics
are gonna obviously all want to watch
right of course but I think every comic
would be like
that's just a process and anyone that
understands like there's no way he's not
going to be not funny sure he's just
gonna not be the what he wants to be
immediately he's just gonna be eat like
there's no way Eddie Murphy can't just
turn the switch on yeah and just do like
the greatest 20 minutes you've ever seen
your whole life like he just does the
old catalog remember people lose their
[__] yeah I think I think it's probably
a combination of fear and like he
doesn't need to do it and it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work yeah it's
Michael it's Michael Jordan coming back
now yeah yeah you know and be like why
I'm past my Prime yeah I've done all
this other [__] leave me the [__] alone
but at least Jordan that's the problem
with comedy Jordan go to the gym and
just shoot threes for five hours alone
in the gym whereas comedy you need the
audience to let you know what's what
Jordan on the Wizards was the clumps
that was Dr Doolittle I got the prior
clip all right let me just see the
camera guy this part kills me
just riffing yeah look at the balls on
this guy this guy would be tight by the
way people give a [__] yeah yeah that's
true
God he's funny he just talks funny
place is going nuts
look at this guy
fulfillment
he kind of looks like me yeah it does
well the camera's broken are you still
going what is this guy must be Autistic
or something I think it's cocaine oh
it's kind of nice so he shook his hand
Jackson
[Applause]
crazy [__] that's a pretty I
mean imagine doing that and being kept
in the special right because I think
people will sometimes get excited when
we just post a dumb because
sometimes people be excited though like
if that's me and the thing you're in in
a Richard Pryor special being an [__]
yeah not like in a good way you're just
like a [__] but it created a funny
moment I'm not defending the guy but it
did create a classic moment have you
felt like you were there at my my first
special taping someone at the nice thing
thanks for putting it right in my mouth
thanks for aiming it right here
but he literally just fed it to me I had
to get it a little up on the mic and I
didn't want to hit him with it no no I
appreciate the anything generation you
know my first the first special yeah uh
there's a girl in the the crap when I
say girl I mean 28 year old woman okay
sitting up front and at the end of the
special like I'm still taping like about
doing closing bit she throws a note on
the stage and she's like she asked me if
I could uh be in her book I'm like this
is and a pink piece of paper pink ink
writes can you be in my book I'm like
this is where you shot your shot wow hey
like that that I didn't I didn't put it
in I didn't keep her in because I'm not
giving this lady any [__] shine good
you know like Get Like Richard Pryor
commend him for be like this guy right
and maybe he was a decision of like this
was fun I bet if it was funny I would
have kept it in but it was I was just
like so annoyed yeah funny Trump's all
yeah how dare you the entitlement of
like this will be my moment yeah I'll
interrupt this guy doing his thing but
to do it at a taping there's cameras
crazy there's crazy there's five eighty
thousand dollar cameras around you you
know what I mean like what the [__] are
you doing the annoying thing is when you
have that great moment and the cameras
aren't rolling like I had that I had
that in there was a mishapping at Wise
Guys comedy club which is one of my
favorite clubs in Utah a mishap where on
Valentine's Day a woman rushed the stage
and enemy roses and I just [__] on her
and I was like this is a great weird
moment yeah and it was like fun we were
like having fun with it but the cameras
were off and I was like ah that would
have been a great one damn because it's
just such a wacky moment yeah I had a
similar thing in Phoenix I'd do a joke
about gay guys like any gay guys here
and a guy goes I think so and it crushed
and then I made fun of him for like five
minutes and they were like oh we forgot
to turn the cameras on Brutal brutal God
damn it yeah
yeah but
that that pink letter [__] or the pink
uh the the what do you mean put you in
her book just put me in the book it's
not a movie it's a book write me in
writing a book about Patel's
okay lady
Jesus you could have just DM me like a
normal person exactly if someone shot me
an email I respond to like most DMS yeah
I'd love to be in the book yeah sure but
not anymore not anymore do you have any
pet peeves nimesh
anything to just bother you about humans
I got one of you don't yeah me too I got
many I mean if I thought about it yeah
probably but take a thing what about
some of your wife does drives you crazy
uh maybe I got one Asians
I got one for you all right go ahead
um when people say that I don't know if
Mark this is like something mark would
say so I don't know if you actually said
this but there's a piece of Mind well we
have similar peeves I feel like okay but
when people ask you to do something and
they go is there any world where you
would do this any world what do you mean
in any world yeah Under the Sea Under
the Sea in that world what do you mean
is there any word where you could see
doing this
just no I don't want to do it it's
always something that you they know you
don't want to do in any world that's
good is there any world where you could
uh pick me up from the airport on Friday
I'm like not this world but I'm sure
there's a world I'm sure there's an
Another Universe West World maybe I'm
sure there's a Rick and Morty extended
world yeah you're going to portal yeah
I'd pick you up but I can drive in that
world I can't drive in this one you
can't drive not really
[Laughter]
yeah they ran over a kid in 88
oh it is a whole new world
in a whole new world could you get me on
your flying carpet what what peeps do
you guys have well I got a uh I went to
LA last week and got a Tesla as a rental
car nice yeah first of all a lot two
hour line at Budget rental car and I was
like what's this line and I noticed
there was a lot of white dreadlocks
around
Coachella got it I didn't know that so
everybody's getting their rental car to
drive out to the desert but I finally
got up to the counter and she goes for
15 more you want to go to Tesla I said
I've never driven one I'm in did they
have to give you the pep talk how to
drive it I said I'll figure it out
really it took me a good 20 minutes in
the driveway or the parking lot but they
usually give you the rundown yeah but I
tried to I was like I got it I got it
even though I didn't I'm not making no
woman's plan
and I just want to be on my way I don't
have to like wait for a guy and go uh
he's gonna go this is the on switch and
this is the charge you know I'll figure
it out when you get an Uber and they
pick up on a Tesla it is a little
exciting it's fun there's like a moment
where you're like this kind of cool yeah
but point being super fun to drive it's
it's so fast there's no gear so it just
just accelerates super fun but she goes
hey just want to let you know if you
don't return it 70 charged we're gonna
[__] you in the ass
[Laughter]
we'll [__] do it
yeah another guy's calling out in all
fours like
it was a boring company poured right to
my taint but I go I got it no problem
I'll find a charger these charges are
hidden all over the town I can't find
any of them I couldn't figure out any
way to charge it so I had to turn it in
with like 12 percent better that's
that's see that's one of the things they
tell you when you pick up the Tesla is
that you could just look for charging
stations on that big map but they'll
just point the Tesla oh I try I tried
all that they're all like in
neighborhoods one was in a parking
structure so I was like all right I
guess I'll go into a parking shirt I had
to get a ticket the arm goes up so now
you're paying for parking while you
charge your car listen to this [__] this
is when the technology [__] you so I
finally find a charger and you have to
sign up for the app sorry all right let
me sign up for the app clock's ticking
the flight's gonna take off so I'm
trying to charge this [__] thing at
eight in the morning no service in a
structure so I have to run out of the
structure get the app go back in I mean
and I just said [__] it I'd rather get
it to me a similar thing happened to me
I had to get I had to get a letter
notarized recently oh no one [__]
notarizes
yes
notarize that's [__] with all these
notaries hanging around so I had to
download an app and then I paid for the
app the app everything is everything's
an app now everything's an app that's
the next John Wick movie they're like
you got to get a letter note
that's a tremendous pet peeve of mine
it's not people it's just everything's
being Amplified and I [__] hate it
agreed no I don't need an app to eat
your pizza yeah exactly give me the
[__] pizza or pizza yeah I'm here you
know when you park on the street and
they're like oh to get the parking slip
you got to get the app of the parking
beater and you're like God damn it just
let me put coins in this [__] yeah why
are you trying to steal my data to [__]
some parking here I know and then now
you got a new [__] button on your
phone that you'll never use oh and
you're going through your apps you're
like why does my phone have no storage
oh yeah because I had to download
Crackle for some reason
I got one for you another peeve
OCD people just bug me I'm sorry I I
know it's a disorder it just feels like
the most narcissistic disorder they use
it people who are like if I don't wash
my hands 47 times and twirl three this
plane's going down I'm like what kind of
who Do You Think You Are God yeah you
think your hands aren't washed it's
gonna punish everyone at 400 other
people on your [__] flight why did
the United flight go down because uh
Jimmy didn't Purell what do you mean
it's very self-involved it's [__]
insane no I'm with you my pet peeve is
when people are one of my pet peeves
people are
at like a like the Delta Lounge Buffet
and they like don't know how to sneeze
properly oh
I'm like oh like I don't know I think a
lot of people learn to sneeze like this
but you're supposed to sneeze into your
elbow yeah and for whatever reason like
I'm just like I gotta get up this
[__] line here goes this I'm gonna go
outside and eat at the bar because I
can't eat any of this [__] anymore
negative like the soup or something
that's closed off yeah by the way it's
always [__] you would never eat in that
thing but when you're in love like I'm
like yo get a loaded baked potato soup
you would never order that anywhere but
adult you're like yeah this doesn't
count no you know what it's like it's
like a movie on a plane you're like I
would never watch uh Traveling Pants or
whatever the [__] The Sisterhood but on
a plane I'm like I'll watch it oh it can
I [__] on United for a second please let
me just suck them here yesterday what
the f like they have eight movies on
there I know eight movies and they're
old and they don't even start you can't
like select them to start you gotta like
wait you select them and then you gotta
wait five minutes for it to sync up you
can't like you can't leave it and come
back otherwise it's [__] never a
movie you want to watch either it's
always like Homeward Bound
Tom Hanks has not been in a watchable
movie in a really long time I started
making some poor decisions I love Tom
Hanks but like what's going on some
money doing something which one I was
boring as hell he sucked in Elvis He had
the bad accent he's been in some stinky
a man called Otto was quite possibly one
of the worst movies you watched it I've
never heard that was in punchline no man
it was on it was on the United plane I
thought that was used for emphasis no
man it was it was it that [__] hurt my
feelings sitting there watching they're
like why the [__] did I commit to I was
thinking yeah now what's going on with
me and Bluetooth why can't I get any
Bluetooth working
I don't know well I try to sing up to
the Tesla it's really annoying and if
you can't get Bluetooth going you're
just [__] yeah we're still relying on
this technology now that it doesn't work
you're just sitting there listening to
your [__] thoughts it's hell it's
hell so now I'm playing a podcast on my
phone like this while driving because I
couldn't get it to get into the system
have you ever hung over on a flight and
the Wi-Fi doesn't work and you can't
talk to someone in the outside world and
you're like I'm gonna [__] kill
myself
[__] mind yeah I I disconnect
I love
I love a plain five out like
cross-country flight not when I'm
hungover though oh okay you don't get
that hangover anxiety no I don't drink
that heavily on the road because I know
if I did I'd turn into you guys
clip it
but like it's just that that five like
the Cross Country flight
five hours not talking to anybody just
me myself a notebook maybe you know
Delta's robust selection of fine films
that's a good selection and you know
what's good about Delta I mean we're
really sucking off Delta here but
they've got the classics they've got
documentaries yeah action Adventures
look I can watch his girl Friday what is
this oh wow what is this [__] AMC
presents you got 30 for 30. yes
you don't know Beau that's next up on
mine I heard Delta's got a man named
Otto on it
by the way all Mark's peeves could have
been solved if they listened to that
lady at budget what do you mean the
Bluetooth didn't work I don't know where
to plug the car in well here's the real
I'm sorry who are you Mark's wife you
never listen
here's the real [__] stain about the the
Bluetooth I got in the car and started
working immediately and I was like I
didn't have to sync it up and then I got
in the car again after going to the
store and it didn't work
yeah not working is annoying because you
realize like all this [__] was so simple
when we just had a plug like that aux
cord was just easy or you have the when
sometimes you're you're trying to get
your phone cooking I'm like this is when
you get hit by the car by the way yeah
it's when you're like why won't it
connect inch that's your that's your
[__] ending right so true that's when
you get hit well you know what they say
the more smart the smarter technology
gets the Dumber people get yeah you know
yeah like think about how many phone
numbers you used to know how many
addresses used to know now it's all in
there phones are getting better we're
getting worse you got that phones are
Getting Thinner we're not we're not no
I'll tell you no respect
this is Mel Brooks
three thousand year old man
[Laughter]
yeah these are these are hidden knives
these drinks I like them are you
drinking as well no I'm cheating over
here drinking club soda and clubs
delicious I'm actually a driver so as
soon as I leave here
driving oh I didn't know that okay yeah
hope your Bluetooth works
seriously what are we talking Town Car
Uber yeah very little right outside I
love the Italian yeah those are things
look like I don't know what they look
like is that like Italian Job type Mini
Cooper type car or what similar a little
different that was kind of vehicle in
New York City Park it is the greatest
you can park anywhere it's like a micro
penis
[Laughter]
parking works if you have a small dick
yeah excuse me you have to move I can
park here no spot wants to have you if
you got a micro dig that one right there
red
um it's actually white that's a Mini
Cooper yeah there you go that was that
was a fun less that's a mini cool just
driving those tiny cars oh yeah great
Movie remake yeah I never saw the
original when's the last time you drove
somewhere
I'm a terrible driver dude so I uh my ex
was like I want to see how bad a driver
you actually are so she's pulled over in
like a in like a parking lot and she was
like this is pretty bad wow and there's
no one around I was like man I was like
it's not that bad she was like it's
[__] bad patreon Mark teaches Sam to
drive I would love to teach you to drive
really I could teach you to drive stick
tomorrow really yeah not on my car
though
what are you driving I got a 1973 BMW 02
that's right should we actually do a
patreon of this that would be pretty fun
go to or get a rental car from uh
turo there you go
yeah they got nice stuff they got some
good tuna
nice nice
what's that mean a Toro yeah oh I was
making it was like a Norman type joke it
was for you is that a type of tuna yes
oh okay I didn't know that I'm sorry
this is pretty amazing this is in
Germany this woman was this girl
and uh she asked her friend what does
this mean like frauing parking plots and
she told her what it means
oh that's not what I wanted uh you were
really you're on a cold streak today man
come on you couldn't find the Nutella
thing I wanted earlier you're pulling up
nonsense what the [__] is going on can I
explain this other than this is pretty
funny so uh she pulls into the parking
spot and she asks her friend what does
this sign mean and it turns out the sign
means women's parking
and she said well why is it women's
parking don't look at the screen she's
advised at Women's parking and she said
oh cause we make the spaces bigger
yeah and what I like about it is it's
like the super utilitarian we're not
making a judgment about we are making a
judgment women drivers are just like
they keep hitting cars so he made the
spaces wider yeah yeah they're very
practical as German they're practical
what do they got for the Asian people
[Music]
that's what I'm saying he can say it
yeah you know you know no one ever talks
about an Asian fish oh you bailed on me
on that so fast
this is my Shane Gillis moment
I think too late I think Asian drivers
are terrific yeah we are I remember
driving once and it was so bad that you
ever have that where you have to just
like some guy's like [__] you you
I know
I'm [__] bad I'm sorry you ever see
the Tim Robinson thing pull up the Tim
Robinson driving thing just go to like
the meat of it like uh this is [__]
this is one of my favorites Tim is the
funniest person my favorite I love this
show yeah pull this up
is he a bad driver here
just go to like 30 seconds and when it
starts
what is your problem man you know how to
[__] drive no
what no I don't know how to [__]
drive I don't know what any of this [__]
is Sam what are you talking about
not everybody knows how to do everything
driving into the only thing
oh my God just grab the steering wheel
s
somebody please face swap Sam into this
video
job interview and I turn out to be the
ball I'm not going to a job interview
[Laughter]
folks we might be drunk as brought you
by sheathed underwear the official
underwear of Comedy what do you got
uh oh he's got it usually you're only
wearing women's panties I just assume
I'm wearing it and that's what sheath
wears they make women's pads true is
dude that's true I could I could get my
little panty line support from a [__]
war hero yeah if you're trying to open
your dick stuck to your balls and your
balls stuck to your leg and your legs
stuck to your dick it's time to try
sheath and as two paintings have dicks
now too that's true good point you're
right we don't discriminate two pouches
one for the dawn one for the ball sheath
underwear comes in tons of cool patterns
to help you look and feel comfortable
you know we love it we're wearing them
right now it really is the best
underwear it's the best I have I have a
friend who whenever he's over he's like
do you have extra and sometimes I do and
I give it to him and he's like that's a
that's a good because he's like I want
it but it's expensive and I was like
it's not that it's for what you're
getting it lasts oh yeah I gave outside
Steve like 10 pairs really yeah because
I had so many and he's taller than me so
I was like these gonna fit go nuts so uh
they didn't leave out the ladies either
shoot those boys short sports bras
bikini briefs go to sheet.aware.com use
promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order every order comes with
sheets 100 money back guarantee that's
sheet underwear.com promo code drunk
good sheath underwear and let them
support your balls hey folks we might be
drunkers brought to you by fume cold
turkey is delicious but cold turkey is a
terrible way to break your bad habits
fume is the fun all-natural way that can
help you kick that habit fume uses all
natural delicious flavored air for you
to breed so you can replace that hand to
mouth feel no electronics no Vapor no
harmful chemicals that makes sense
because it's really all about that oral
fix say you know you just gotta go back
and forth back and forth something to do
often we walk into a social situation I
tend to grab a beer or grab my tits but
yeah you gotta uh you gotta do something
and fume is a way to do it but without
killing yourself those Vapes I don't
trust them I'm not I'm a vape apologist
so I think it looks good it feels good I
took a few whiffs myself and I God it
tastes great
and the new version is fun to play with
fun to hold and you pull it out it's a
conversation starter it's a good time
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
give your fingers a lot to do and help
you de-stress while breaking your habit
put a [__] on there let me play with
that
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching a fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fuma
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume to
help break up your destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trifum.com and use code drunk to save
10 off when you get the journey pack
today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code drug to
save an additional 10 off your order
today get some fume it's finally spring
and the weather is warming up
don't spend all your free time chopping
vegetables
enjoy the great outdoors and let Factor
do the cooking for you factor is
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit delivers nutritious meals straight
to your door leaving you more time to
get outside and soak up the sun
factors always fresh never frozen meals
take just two minutes to prepare so
you'll be eating well no matter how
hectic your schedule becomes with over
34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
options each week there's always
something new and exciting to try Factor
meals come in a variety of Lifestyle
options so if you're vegan vegetarian
keto or calorie counting there's
something delicious waiting for you head
to factormeals.com
drunk50 and use the code drunk50 to get
50 percent off your first box
that's code drunk 50 at factormeals.com
drunk50 to get 50 off your first box
best
yeah you gotta learn to drive my my lady
can't drive and it sucks we'll go on
road trips and I'm like just give me
like an hour you drive for an hour and
she'll drive for like 10 seconds and I'm
like I gotta she's that bad it's bad
she's Boston
nah she's from The Burbs but I think she
just doesn't care enough she's like not
dedicated enough to not she'd rather
look at her phone than Rick you know in
Germany shift it right in huh Germany
that's right that's right but she hits
the curb immediately or like the guy
next door is like you're coming to my
Lane and uh it's like pull it over I
gotta drive you taking that Beamer
anywhere fancy I took it to gigs that
are like an hour and a half away no no
further I'm too scared of getting uh
stranded oh it breaks down all the time
it never has but I'm I know it's coming
you know it's uh those gigs early on
when I'd be opening for people and
they'd be like you can drive right and
I'd be like yeah and then we'd I'd be
driving I remember I was with opening
for a guy and he was like pull over dude
yeah he's like this is bad he like
brought me so he could like work on his
laptop while I drove and then he was
pretty [__] pissed and it was Tracy
Morgan
I drove Jay had a gig in like like a
college gig very Shake hand driver I
can't drive I would think yeah most city
kids can't drive uh uh what's it called
I think it was probably we were like
four years he had just gotten SNL or
something he's doing SNL so he had like
a big college gig or something and he we
were driving I was driving and it was
one of these moments where I was like I
should not be driving because we were in
a car that should not be in the snow oh
and I could tell which I'd never driven
before because I'm white knuckling this
thing where it's snowing we're going
Upstate New York we're behind like a
salt truck and it's like spraying salt
that doesn't change it's playing on his
phone
super casual meanwhile has a cliff on
one side and like a bunch of houses on
the other like we were about to die bro
you understand like I'm going 20 miles
an hour you're going down like and he's
on snood what the [__] [__] Sudoku
I want to take I want to get a car in
the city like I may it be this year or
next year now why
isn't just a huge waste of money here I
think there's a I think you get a lot of
you can expand the things you do that
aren't common I agree like I wanna I
wanna go hiking and [__] I want to like
just take blood
get on the train
what's that that Hudson Valley Drive
though it's beautiful yeah that's
beautiful so it was a train up the
Hudson that's true
very nice
you take a a train up there and you rent
a car or you Uber or something yeah but
you know he's got a couple bucks now you
live in what Brooklyn yes sir oh you got
a little space out there we're working
you know just taking taking a little
Cruise out that was nice I just think in
New York do you have a car no never had
a car I don't know I never had a car
never had a car well he's from he's from
New York too got my license when I was
28. oh [__] damn Drive I've been in the
car with you I'm a driver yeah he's
pretty good yeah yeah I had to get in
Poughkeepsie two weekends ago and not
bragging but uh that drive up maybe
because it made the trip beautiful
beautiful Town well that we it's so
weird that I mean it depends where you
go obviously but that that train ride
going to like Albany it's beautiful oh
yeah until you get to Albany yeah and
then you're like what the [__] oh my God
the beauty ends at the sign that says
welcome to all of them and Cuomo grabs
you
yeah yeah that really is a dump Albany
yeah Buffalo as well
Syracuse no Buffalo is pretty Buffalo's
got hard Buffalo's the best one I like
Buffalo when did you go to Buffalo last
less than a year I went to Buffalo in
October great food great people you have
have you been to chefs the Italian food
in Buffalo is excellent and the wings
are incredible I I got a weird Love For
What buffalo wings there you go I got
love for Buffalo Syracuse is a [__] hole
I did Albany in Syracuse and Hartford in
a three-day one-nighter run oh that's
the Bermuda Triangle it was brutal that
doesn't even make sense in terms of
routing it did I think it was hard for
first and then uh
it should be you just walking into
Hartford getting stabbed doing the gig
yeah you're going to Buffalo you get
stabbed we do another one we're driving
up and there was a three four hour pile
up on the highway so it took like we
went straight from Hartford dropped all
our [__] off at the hotel and then had
to jet to the uh I think a heart Albany
Funny Bone or Syracuse Funny Bone one of
those two clubs this place is ass that's
Syracuse funny bone that mall
is really like if you don't get shot
there consider it a w
really a [__] dump I'll be there this
summer guys coaches the coach's wife got
[__] mugged there really wow yeah the
coaches well that's all there is in that
town the orange it's the player they got
cut from the team yeah nice one I've
shot him that way look up pull up Chef's
Restaurant in um Buffalo dude it's like
a pasta parm it's like a brick of cheese
I mean look you're gonna want to commit
suicide after eating it but it's the
best [__] thing you've ever put in
your mouth it's unreal um just a brick
of cheese and pasta
um
I mean we made the mistake I was with of
course uh kid garissimo Gary veteran oh
yeah and he was like let's [__] he's
like let's go to this place before the
show oh I want to die yeah of course
that was also the infamous oyster
weekend where Gary thought it was a good
idea to get take out oysters
oh Buffalo
he's like it's fine shut up and he takes
e slurps one I'm like yeah [__] it what
the hell we'll go down together so I
slurp one I listen to him on stage I can
hear him on stage going
and I'm like oh [__] it's gonna hit me
in a second so I go on station
[Music]
optimism you guys are so brave to be I
don't eat Brave we're [__] idiots
before each I mean those are two
synonymous things
video like two brothers you know but I I
rarely eat before getting on stage I
can't no it's a nice thing it's like a
nice reward usually for after the
session but if you're doing two shows
you usually plans after you do in
between right yeah but nothing's open
when I get off stage so I always eat
before Oh no I do in between if I'm
doing two but if I do one yeah I mean I
like it's nice to have something to look
forward to yeah yeah I do the diva shoe
out of the club bring me something while
I'm on stage like in The Green Room yeah
that's a good move do one of those you
know so speaking of the road are you
guys working on any new bits oh
right now on stage I'm talking about
going to therapy and it's like is
therapy new for you yes it's very new
well what what prompted the therapy
decision I'm trying to stop touching
kids we'll see
it's not easy to quit I got the patch
yeah no it's just uh doing the gum it
was it was what we were talking about
earlier about like coming home that
night when I was super drunk my wife was
like you got like I have definitely like
latent anger issues from when I grew up
as a kid how I grew up as a kid and like
finally this year I was like I should
probably see somebody just stop hitting
her and you talk about it sure is this
from the parents either the anger stuff
or is this like parents family yeah for
sure okay is anyone else in your family
in therapy yes multiple people in my
family are in therapy as they should be
I think everyone Indian people don't go
you're right yeah I'm just trying I
don't think it's fine I don't think it's
a necessity therapy but I do think a lot
of the people that are like therapy is a
joke really needs therapy they really do
yeah how long have you been going I
haven't been in a while but I I went for
a long time right very long time have
you gone I've been going for years now
yeah I pushed Mark into it he got me in
and what do you think I love it Game
Changer although Alan art there purpose
pulled a weird one the other night tell
me if you've had this I leave there we
had a good sesh 20 minutes late I got a
text he goes I I thought of something
else can we do another session and I'm
like well wait a minute is this a grift
yeah he owes a boogie dude it's like hey
I got I need you to come back and you
know it's like an upsell right no I
haven't had I mean my therapist my
therapists only worked for me with me
I've only worked with my therapist for
like
six sessions now okay and it does it I'm
always like it's so expensive sure it's
insane it's so much for you to just lie
to yourself well that's the thing
that's true you know that's true just
not talk to anybody but it is incredibly
expensive but this is the good part it's
almost like a relationship where the
beginning is the most fun so you have a
you have a male therapist but I haven't
gone in a while but yay was a man did
you did you purposely make that decision
or were you like no I think like if it
was a woman I would have been open to
that but then there's definitely that Dr
melfy sexual chemistry sure you got that
right yeah you want to [__] Alan yeah
yeah but I use those tissues
that's the [__] I'm working on right now
no we uh
is yours a woman yeah mine is a woman
but it was she hot
I don't find her attractive no perfect
yeah white lady yes okay but I I the
first therapist I went to was probably
20 right before pandemic happened 20 20
20. oh wow your therapist was 20. no no
no no good Vision Doogie Howser you just
need a tick tock
have you tried athletic greens it was a
it was uh it was an Indian woman and uh
because I was told like go if you're
gonna go therapist as an Indian person
you should probably talk to someone
Indian who understands like the cultural
context of that makes sense you're gonna
be talking about
and I started talking to her and it just
the vibe was off from the sense of like
she was just like on her phone like
listening on her phone like it felt like
she was just like being dismissive huh
and I was like okay well
but it was even in that session that I
had like a breakthrough I was like okay
this lady's not it yeah if I wanted to
talk to someone who's just gonna ignore
me the whole time I would just been on a
date with Indian chick as opposed to me
but with but the next person I like I
started Googling recently to find
somebody and then the most qualified
people are women in terms of like like
PhD in trauma psychology or like a
matter of trauma what's that do you
think I have a lot of trauma for sure so
my cousin
my cousin is an alcoholic and we grew up
together and so my well we grew up
together and he basically saw the same
[__] that he saw that made him who he is
made him have what he has so I was like
I probably got some [__] in my brain
that I didn't has manifested as comedy
as opposed to boozing all the time but
I should probably talk to somebody at
this at the same level yeah and if a
trauma psychologist can handle like a
war vet she can right handle this
[__] dumbass you know but I've only
killed like one person so it's like what
are you gonna do is there are you still
closer to your cousin is he alcoholic
yeah yeah we talk all the time and your
cousin is like it's a serious problem
well he's he's sober now uh but yeah it
was it was a serious problem and hope
he's like on demand and talking to
therapists and come on what'd you see
dead body
domestic violence oh okay and which is
strange because like none of our parents
were cops you know it's like when we
never saw
we just it was just like Indian people
go through a lot yeah at least a
generation above me went through a lot
of [__] and so like for them to not for
them to be like we don't need it it was
your parents no not my parents ah but it
was always it was always around it was
always lingering yeah and so it would be
like it was in your family for sure so
seeing that made it like I know that
impacted me subconsciously like I don't
remember [__] in my childhood and I
should yeah you think it blocked it out
it's probably just gone yeah where the
[__] is it I think I got a few of those
too this repressed memories yes and I'm
I don't want them to come up because I
think they're pretty dark you can hear
more about it in Mark's new one-man show
Daddy now
it's a really really strong one
but like that that made me
like I should talk to somebody like I
don't have I'm not like out punching
people and hitting things yeah like I
know that's in me right like there's an
anger in me for sure I've never seen
that side of you and and we don't know
each other super well three more of
these baby I've been drunk with you
before and you're not a bad drunk I
think that's part of the problem too is
like you can use this [__] as medicine
none of us are bad drunks yeah so we can
keep drinking the bad drunks usually
have to quit I'm assuming your cousin
who is an alcoholic either it was
affecting his life in some way or he was
a bad drunk he was not a bad drunk
that's the scary part yeah
[Music]
big some of the best quote-unquote
alcoholics you don't even know right
they're just like for years I mean
granted so what made him quit
he hit uh Rock Bottom it was like uh it
was like mid pandemic where he was just
like he was trying to quit himself and
when you're an alcoholic tries to quit
themselves they go cold turkey they go
through withdrawal withdrawal for an
alcoholic for someone who's been
drinking for a very long time is like
you get you pass out and get the shakes
that's why I don't quit you know keep
going and uh and he's just like he
called me is like bro I need you to come
here I'm like what's wrong he's like I I
just passed out in the bathroom I'm like
what and then we went down he told us
all this [__] I was like what the [__]
like for years we didn't know like like
a like pints a day habit whoa how the
[__] are you functioning bro and then
you know you got a kid on the way at the
time it's like oh this you you have to
change because this is not healthy and
my cous other cousins are doctors like
yeah this is you on the path to being
dead by 50 if you keep drinking like
this
because it's like
we [__] around with this kind of stuff
but like the way he was drinking it was
like you you are drinking way too much
like a pint every yeah two hours or so I
was like you're gonna die yeah that's
crazy you know pint of liquor but
absolute vodka
weird plug but drink up guys
everybody remember when absolute had
those really cool ads when it was like
oh absolute like tough guy would be like
Steve McQueen the absolute this and then
be like the absolute vodka and you're
like I'm not gonna lie for as far as ad
sales go not not too shabby no no we
used to have them up on the wall they
had that they had that campaign was it
them or Smirnoff
but you have a drink with you oh [__] I
don't want to hear that no
no I would not that's why I drink you
yeah yeah I hate myself yeah the drink
silences me
damn when uh when Smirnoff took over for
that as like the bond vodka and I was
like slow down Bonbon yeah no it was
like vote James like James Bond would
order like a Smirnoff and I'd be like
what is he a 13 year old girl yeah but
I'm just drinking Smirnoff now come on
no you order [__] Goose or like some
classy vodka of your [__] Bond or
some [__] you never heard of yeah some
Polish Russian cool [__] yeah right yeah
Smirnoff shaken not starch we had a
that's my audition they're looking for a
new guy we need an Indian bond we do
who is the next bond is like one of the
things where like it may be like Idris
Elba like aged out of it now because he
would have been the cool choice I think
because yeah because he was so [__]
cool and Luther oh yeah so cool and he's
he's British too
[__] but you need like but they're
probably gonna go younger because they
want to franchise that [__] I think Ed
Sheeran
I hope they go Dev Patel that's my vote
Dev Patel James
he was in uh his biggest role was a a
Slumdog Millionaire oh yeah yeah my vote
goes to uh Dylan Mulvaney I think that
she would make a great Bond look at this
beautiful man yeah not too shabby he's
got to do it oh yeah better than Cal
Penn
he's just too goofy he's too silly no
one's even mentioning him in the morning
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that's way better he's hotter he's
swapped man it's a swab dude yeah oh
he's the guy in the deaf movie yeah it's
not a middle sound of metal he's a
killer that's a that's a bond right yeah
he's short ah
[Music]
man I was watching by the way great such
a classic Tootsie was on TV the other
day that's such a funny movie man great
movie Dustin Hoffman would just [__]
killed it and then yeah yeah drag Greg
yeah I had him abandoned Nashville
[Laughter]
it's a really hurtful movie no uh he
kills it it's such a funny movie Jessica
Lange was a [__] dime piece oh so hot
she was great bone structure I know I
sound like a serial killer she had great
uh
Indian bond we got something here that
would be fun yeah it would never happen
the Brits would never allow it but ah
true oh we do are we working on bits now
you so what's give us a therapy bit
you're working on I think I did a lot of
them
oh yeah what do you got I got one so I
was seeing a woman who uh this is the
idea I have I don't know where to go
with it quite yet but she told me we did
that thing we dig into the sexual pass
which is always a very smart game to
play with it yeah the body counts no
drama ever comes from that and uh she
divuls and she slept with Liam Neeson
once
a particular set of skills
he's a huge dong by the way I don't know
if you've heard that pull it up she said
he was she said he wasn't great she said
it wasn't good whatever but I heard I
didn't go into that I've heard that too
we didn't go into detail but here's the
thing
here's the angle I have I don't know if
you ever watched uh Schindler's List and
got bummed out for a different reason oh
that's great that's great and then
something like this line didn't hit but
there's something like this where I'm
like watching it like hey Oscar you left
one name off that list
you know what I mean yeah there's got to
be something I think it's hilarious to
watch to like realize because
Schindler's List I definitely was
stopped pulling up pictures up
her virginity was taken all right
sorry sorry no I like this it's
Schindler's listing for the there's
something for a different reason is
great and there's something about
watching that movie where you're just
like this is uh
it's funny to be like wow I never
realized how sad this movie was you know
like we mean all the Jews you're like
nah nah
that's good I don't know I'm thinking
there's something there though right
yeah definitely what do you got Marcus
all right this this is a a bit of a
stretch maybe but I can't end this joke
it's hitting up top and it falls off a
cliff so I went to this party in
Brooklyn Warehouse rager DJ people
dancing I went with a buddy he goes man
it's a zoo in here and I was like it's
weird that people say that because you
ever been to a zoo pretty orderly you
know it's just people walking around
taking photos what animals sleeping yeah
a lot of sleeping animal this is like
people always said about a while this
place is wild it's a zoo but the zoo is
the opposite of wild
the wild is wild and then I need an
ending that part all hits I've never
seen a panda get taken out in a headlock
yeah did you see a woman [__] in the
corner just yeah don't walk away from
him all right by the way it was like a
zoo what are their children there
I don't know also like uh I went to an
old folks home once and it's sad they're
not allowed to leave I'm like this is a
zoo
in here they're gonna die here yes yes
they were put in here by you know their
children yeah it was adaptive the only
difference between the old folks home
and the zoo is uh the old folks home no
one visits oh oh good tag good tag all
right I love it hey
comedy I was just trying to think of how
you could tie Cuomo into that somehow
killing all the old people but I don't
see I haven't I haven't made the leap
yet jokes are [__] fun yeah yeah I
love jokes dude this is a this is an
area I'm playing with but this is a true
story like
a few weeks ago I went to Bloomingdale's
it was like this middle-aged white guy
in there
and he's yelling at no one in particular
like little just yelling at people I
need a tuxedo no one's helping me find
he's like yep yep strip yeah I
confronted him I was like bro this thing
this is not the subway you can't just be
yelling at people he's like get away
from me you're being a bully right now
um and I will I laughed because I was
about to [__] twist his titties and
[__] but like I try to do the right
thing at all times and and I've walked
away from this guy after just like
laughing his face and and my therapist
was like so what do you think you did
wrong you walked you confronted him you
told him to calm down he walked away I
was like
I knew where the tuxedos were the whole
time I'm just gonna go up the stairs
make a left look I don't know I don't
know what the end is yeah Beyond like
what compelled me to confront him as
opposed to telling him hey man like I'll
help you right right what is it in me
that's the comedian you know you want
the funny story
and being like Oh it's right there yeah
[__] yeah there's no justice there no
there's Justice maybe the turn is that
like yeah you have you done this on
stage yet yeah and does it get a laugh
when you go I knew where they were the
whole time yeah but it doesn't feel
complete right right right right yeah
also something funny that this guy is
the biggest [__] but he's trying to
be formal right like I like the idea
like who's who's marrying your daughter
sir this poor you know new boyfriend is
[__] this store's not that big man
yeah what event is having you yes
hopefully it's a funeral
though yeah it's like he's the worst
James Bond ever I thought about I
thought about I hope your Gala gets
canceled I hope you gotta wear a suit
yeah like an [__] like that but it's
so where's the tuxedo but if you helped
him he would have thought you worked
there and then you'd be suiting this guy
up for a tuxedo right yeah you're right
and then he was just gone on living his
shitty entitled life exactly what did he
look what was his Vibe middle-aged white
dude Rolex and one wrist French Bulldog
on the other damn
um like Rolex on one of the French
Bulldogs wrists yes and uh this guy was
moneyed up not muddied enough to be at
Bergdorf but money enough to be yelling
at Bloomingdale's looking for a tuxedo
right it's like who the [__] what kind
of that's strange he accused you of
being the bully when he's clearly yeah
yes
projecting I don't I just told him like
Hey just don't yell at people just be
polite like what the [__] are you doing
here like yeah he he's conf he said
don't talk to me like that you don't
know who I am it could be funny to be
like and they say uh hey don't yell at
people it's not nice you're like I
should have known that was a bad move
just from my relationship but uh or
something like that yeah yeah that
doesn't work with women either when you
say hey don't yell it doesn't stop no no
calm down yeah every tell women to calm
down they don't calm down they don't
call them yeah people don't like that
yeah what if I What if I find what if I
go to where the tuxedos are and put one
on like this is where they are like oh
yeah I don't know what the end is yeah
because you know you know you have a bit
where like oh the bones are there you
want the the button yeah like I gotta
close it up yeah walk out of the store
with the tux in my bag kind of thing
that's what it feels like huh I'm adding
that into the therapy chunk of just like
you know a therapy material just like I
am trying to be I didn't help him yeah
there's something funny about like I
didn't help him like that that I think
bringing it back to you is where the
joke is going to end up being you know
so why did you confront him
part of me was well part of me was like
he was just yelling at people and
another part of me was one of those
staff that walked past him because it
seemed like the staff was ignoring him
like he was just like a [__] lunatic
and he'd just been a [__] to
everybody and one of the staff was like
this probably 70 year old Indian guy who
walked past him and just didn't say
anything and I guess part of me was
triggered by that like my grandpa used
to work at Macy's right and I was just
like
who the [__] are you just yelling at
people in the store yeah like I've never
been in a situation where I'm looking
for something
belittle people because I'm not getting
help I'm like I'm of the mind like I'll
look for a [__] myself until for the
last second or I'll just pick hey excuse
me sir yeah you'd be decent well I mean
yeah I mean I have a bit of my last
special where
a woman was just being horrible to a TSA
agent and Veteran and I confront her and
we just start talking [__] to her and
it's like yeah there's there's it's
about Justice the punchline is justice
so it's like something about
who the [__] do you like there should be
rules to get to wear a tuxedo like I'm
sorry sir we can't sell you a tuxedo
it's almost like getting kicked out of
this stuff oh yeah interesting
you're not allowed to wear that because
you're not
you're not sophisticated yeah you're
you're a low-class piece of [__] you
don't get a [__] tuxedo the suits are
over there you know yeah yeah yeah the
sweatpants are down the hall so we're
sorry we can sell you Crocs or
sweatpants at best but yeah this should
be a politeness bra like at a roller
coaster there's a height this should be
politeness this is this isn't it
I'm fishing that that is that is
something you could add into it yes yes
but I think it's about you I think
that's the bit it comes back to you yeah
some misdirection like and then I found
the Tuxedos and I married his daughter
or something somewhere he loses I took
his dog and I don't know I don't know
what it is I took his dog and [__] it
yeah maybe a steal his Rolex at the end
you know huh well this has been fun ah
[__] I know I know this well look we
don't solve all the [__] jokes I know
there's something no there's definitely
something to start a conversation to get
the mind working too yeah like like that
Liam Neeson joke ain't ready for stage
either but it's something there you're
on the way yeah I like it with the with
the the worst thing about the
Schindler's List yeah you can I ask when
you make a reference like that
how confident are you that so you're CR
how old are your crowds I think they're
pretty young I I mean yeah they're all
over the place but you know you get a
little bit of everything when you make
them when you make a reference to a
movie that's 1994 yeah that is like the
that is like the Holocaust reference
though yeah I feel like young people
know that movie it's like an essential
move it's also a Spielberg movie full
assignment I know yeah really yeah yeah
we had to see we didn't see Schindler's
List in school we saw The Pianist oh
also great great movie Brody true story
well you know what's [__] up is he
actually fingered her too
I'm trying to think of an ending to this
joke uh one of my security
um
it's a great movie great movie but it's
three hours of Holocaust death yeah and
a lot of violence but yeah and I think
that's why I was so interesting because
it was too prematures too early the
holocaust movie too much violence yeah
oh yeah I see that yeah when it came out
it was like oh my God this is You Know
Rich When We Were Young when you're
young and they and they show you those
movies you're like holy [__] this is my
intro but that's it's good as a kid to
be shocked I guess you should no it is
after my babysitter
I think it is good I think you should be
shocked and horrified because that's
what it is
you should watch slavery and Holocaust
movies and be like what the [__] of
course it should be in like sixth or
seventh grade and be horrified what do
you think about like taking out the
n-word and Mark Twain and [__]
it's tough I don't I don't like editing
I don't like I don't like editing either
I don't like editing work reality is
real it happens nobody's real it's a
good thing your girlfriend didn't see uh
date chuatel edger for because then you
B wait say that again I know it's a
tough work he was making it out of my
mouth he was making it 12 Years a Slave
job
off the tongue yeah hard name to say
that was 12 years a punch line right
there Jesus Christ
I thought you had a stroke
so did the joke
well dude it's been a great app man
we're happy you came on we plug some
plug some gigs there we go oh and the
new special my new special is called
lucky Lefty it should be out April 30th
hell yeah on YouTube please go watch it
all right and uh yeah we love you man
it's great to see you so much yeah good
stuff definitely definitely support and
follow new mashed potatoes congrats on
the therapy yeah no thank you man true I
know it sounds joking around but truly
like it's not easy to do that [__] yeah
but it means you're you know maturing
progressing I don't think I'm gonna stop
touching kids
it feels good is the problem yeah and
we've been demonetized
yeah a lot of gigs coming up for me what
do we got uh geez when did this come out
late May so go to late May
we go can you read in my eyes yeah June
4th in Richmond and then Greensboro
North Carolina Asheville Charlotte North
Carolina Knoxville Tennessee on June 8th
Memphis Tennessee and we got Birmingham
Chattanooga all over the place I don't
know when this comes out from Memphis
but uh tickets still available yeah God
damn you're working man look at this
[__] Paramount Theater in Denver oh that
one that one we added there so that's
gonna keep please come here and uh uh
Santa Fe San Antonio Houston I love San
Antonio I have like a weird level I was
I was there last week it's like dude
there's something about the Mexican
food's incredible yeah culture is kind
of it's like a cool City when next time
you're in San Antonio go to
um best quality daughter Asian
restaurant uh run by Chef who I think it
was in New York and then moved to San
Antonio a little awkward for a Chinese
place it's did they kill the daughters
no they kept this one it was a quality
dog
it's a very good restaurant
you know we love staviors uh I think
it's 600 000 views in two days that guy
pushes numbers man he did six of the Vic
six of the Wilbur whatever he is killing
it that's free on YouTube if you go to
stavros's page and we have some dates
for me and we love him all right I'll be
in Australia come on out say hello uh
Sydney Brisbane Adelaide you name it
doing a theater tour out there then
announcing a theater tour this summer
with the I don't know Outback or one of
those so uh come on out say hello
marknomencomedy.com
let's thank our bartender Lisa thank you
very much thank you guys list make sure
to buy uh Bodega cat whiskey Bodega
whiskey.com by the time this episode's
out maybe it's [__] legal New York
finally praying a lie it's about [__]
time everybody's asking about it we did
our part you gotta register it yeah it's
a whole legal red tape mumbo jumbo
jumping through hoops
but we're getting there
so thank you thank you thank you give
yourself a tuxedo have a good one
[Music]
I've had a
paddling much burping and Norman's
talking [__] about the [__] Pope and
I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might
be true
[Music]